[Music]
on today's show we talked to a woman who
just got her friend's job and she hasn't
told her friend yet we also talked to a
brand new dad who wants to learn how to
better respect his young daughters when
we talk to a man whose in-laws are
moving in for the summer stay tuned
[Music]
hey what's up this is john with the dr
john delony show what up what up
i hope you're doing awesome
hope your kids are doing well and if you
don't have any kids
you're just looking at your dog or your
cat i hope you're not thinking man i'm
such a great cat parent but you're just
thinking i'm a good pet owner that's
awesome too whoever you happen to be i'm
glad you're with us if you're just i
don't know walking down the street or
riding one of those uh tricycle
motorcycles
actually you can just go to another
podcast there's a million other ones you
can listen to actually you know what
this podcast is for you tricycle
motorcycle driver
what do you call those things
i don't know that's that sounds right to
me that's what they look like tricycle
motorcycles
with a pet stick with the pet parent
sticker on the back
oh my gosh that's incredible that's all
my favorite things in one human hey on
this show we talk about mental health
relationships and motorcycle tricycles
everything if you want to be on the show
give us a
six
shout
1-844-693
thirty two ninety one it's one eight
four four six nine three three two nine
one or go to johndaloni.com ask john
delany.com ask so glad you're here let's
get right to the
c-a-l-l-s let's go to donna in philly
what up donna how are we doing
hi john what's up
no not much i'm a dog lover
are you a dog lover are you a dog parent
because i'm a dog lover
i'm a dog parent of three oh no
no
tell me all about them where'd they come
from what are their names
all that's right
rusty ripley and spencer
what happened to spencer why did he get
an r name
well because he wasn't supposed to be
mine
oh you you're a dog parent kidnapper
dude i like where this is i am i am
that's a whole there's a whole like
podcast sub genre below murder podcast
our parent
podcast yeah and then pet parent thieves
podcast yes
yes no he was supposed to be my dog my
daughter's service dog it didn't work
out because he didn't like men
so i got him
dang
that's a whole nother show men hating
yeah
how's rusty i had an awesome friend
named rusty one of the greatest guys
i've ever known um how's what kind of
dog is rusty
rusty is a cockapoo all three of them
are cockapoos oh just cocker spaniel
all your dogs look the same that's even
more creepy hey
do you remember in seinfeld they had
that horse named rusty they kept farting
all the time that was awesome yeah
anyway
excellent
rusty does too
must be something with the name no my
friend rusty he didn't he never did that
he's just awesome guy um
okay so
pet parent pet parent
you don't have one of those uh tricycle
motorcycles do you
no i don't have a trike do you listen to
rush
no okay now we're back now we're back
all right so what's up all right i'm
calling because i have a question
regarding work issue all right bring it
on all right
my supervisor left about a year ago to
go on
leave
and then her replacement went out in
march
so they asked me to fill in temporarily
through the supervisor role i didn't
want to do it had no desire was happy
where i was i was like nope don't want
it
personally really didn't think like i
could do it
i actually like the job of course you do
you're a pet mom of course you do
surprisingly i've actually enjoyed doing
what i'm doing well now that it's been
over a year our handbook says that once
they're out a year their position
isn't held for them they stole the job
in our department
but not necessarily the job that they
were in before okay
management just came to me since it's
been a year and asked me if i wanted the
job permanently
so i said yes
the problem here is did you not tell
your friend
she's also my friend oh no that's my
question
pet parents it always ends up pet
parents
should i tell her yes that's your fault
yes man but i asked management and they
were like we'll tell her when we know
she's coming back because they're not
sure that she's going to come back
okay so
do you still talk to your friend
i do actually when kelly called me she
was on the phone with me
i don't want to be rude but you're the
worst okay so
yeah i know
so hold on so you and i'm smiling when i
said that you're not really lost i mean
you kind of are but um so
i feel like i am i mean your feelings
are correct your feelings are correct
but so
does your friend like talking about when
she's gonna come back and she can't wait
and she's just getting healthy
she's getting healthy because she keeps
saying it's gonna be another month it's
gonna be another now maybe january she's
looking at it
and she knows she knows the rules i know
she knows the rules but you're her
friend
why did she leave what's the medical
issue
i really didn't want to get into that
okay she's got a bunch of health issues
and
all different things okay but she
she doesn't know she's actually going to
be able to come back stress and her body
and how it reacts to stress and all that
but
every time she calls she's always like
how's work and you and she was really
great in the beginning when i took the
job she was like helping me i could call
her at any time i still feel like i
could call her any time but now she
every time she calls she's like so how's
work you haven't been calling me
everything must be going pretty good and
i'm like
yeah and i try to avoid the subject
yeah you gotta i
what is it about y'all's relationship
that you don't tell her
because i'm trying to just imagine in my
head
um like i'm just trying to i'm picking
like i'm trying to todd my buddy todd
and we work at the same place we
actually worked at the same university
for a season and then
he goes out for a year now i'm thinking
out loud here if he was dying of cancer
and he's on cancer leave and slowly is
working his way back
and then i swoop in and take his job and
i don't tell him i'm just like
and then he comes back two months after
the year or six months or whatever
dude okay
now i'm also thinking if he is out with
you know
a
unspecified psychiatric issue like
burnout like i just can't come back
right now i'm gonna take medical leave
and there's just like amorphous
um
my knees hurt and my back hurts and my
neck's got problems and i can't sit at a
computer whatever
but we would have been having that
conversation i don't know i my
friendships are just different and so i
don't know if your friendship is one
that's pretty close
there's something about that you're not
going to tell her because i would just
have had this conversation months ago
i i think we're not
close friends we it's more of a work
friendship like we talk about things
that happen at work i mean i do talk to
her about you know my girls and my dogs
oh geez
do you have human kids too by the way
do you have human kids too
i do i have two girls
see a regular parent do they know that
they are never mind that's a whole other
okay you know what so
at the end of the day yes
you've got to have this conversation
here's where it's gonna be you're gonna
be in a pickle as if your business says
you cannot do that this is an hr issue
you cannot have this conversation and
they said that to you
they didn't say that but they said that
they would discuss it with her when they
knew she was coming back
so that's where i'm kind of like
if i tell her am i going to get in
trouble with work if i don't tell her is
our friendship going to be kind of weird
and then the other part is when she
comes back
how do we work together if i have a job
so
reverse engineering your question
let that happen when that happens
okay
because now you're gonna start okay
here's two things you're gonna do the
first thing you're doing is you're gonna
start catastrophizing because you're on
shaky relational ground so you're going
to start imagining a scene i'm
definitely doing that yes and you're
you're having a bunch of imaginary pre
conversations
and then what happens is you imagine her
saying something and then you imagine
these awesome comebacks that you have
and then your body spins up and goes
into war because that's all it knows how
to do and so you're literally killing
yourself
and i'm not i'm not smiling anymore like
you're literally driving yourself crazy
no you're absolutely right
i literally there's nights i can't sleep
because i'm this conversation keeps
going on in my head yes and then
what you're starting to do is to
minimize your relationship with her
so it went from you we're good friends
too we just talk about dogs and kids
we're just like a work friend so you're
going to continually squash that
relationship and minimize it whereas
what's happening in her world is you're
her only lifeline
yeah i feel like so it is inflating on
her side she's probably over dramatizing
how close y'all are
and okay you are you are just
you're piling coal in your engine and
it's just gonna make the train wreck
bigger when it finally happens
and so all of this and this is this is
me
now talking to all the listeners
all of this gets headed off early
if we have conversations early on hey
they just asked me to be the interim
this is going to be weird
let's talk about it now like if they
offer me this full-time job i don't want
it and then a month in like hey i really
like this i'm loving this i know it's
going to be weird for us it's just
putting all that out there
this is the same conversation never
talked about any of that when i first
took it
really helpful but never really
discussed how that would affect our our
friendship yes and so there's only one
way forward and it's directly in the
middle of it
and just to lean in and probably in
person if at all possible
and do you all hang out ever do you all
go to get a drink or have coffee or
anything you need every once in a while
oh my gosh y'all are in person no
yes yes and so here's your
forward yup
take
way
and say i should have been having this
conversation with you a long time ago
i'm so sorry here's where we are and if
you're mad i totally get it if you are
upset i totally get it or if you're
excited for me i totally get it but
here's the situation
right like i feel like it'll she'll put
up a good front but internally she's
gonna
take it really hard well and that's not
your job
um
your job isn't to man until she hears
this it's to be hospitable and kind and
own up i should have been having this
conversation with you a long time ago
and i didn't
right
yeah
i hate this i hate this for you i mean i
just hate it for i know it's a messy
situation it's just so
awkward and if she's got any sort of
psychological issues that she stepped
away for i i imagine that will make this
that will compound this challenge
um if she's coming back with
any
it may be a gift let's let's do the
optimistic side it she may be stressed
on i don't know how to come back as a
supervisor
and it may be a gift probably not but we
can make it that way i don't know
but yes there's only one way forward and
that is to have this direct conversation
okay cool will you let me know how that
goes
sure
awesome i can't i can't i literally
can't wait but yes
hug rusty and spencer the the night
before
okay and they'll give you
pet parent superpowers or something like
that probably not but um good for you
but yeah it's time you got to have that
conversation [ __ ] had a while ago but
here we are so let's just move forward
and let's have it and let's be
remorseful you know that you should have
been having this conversation and you
know it's going to be awkward and for
everybody out there
not having hard conversations is just
like spending out of your checking
account and never checking the balance
there will come a moment
when the late fees start rolling in and
it will be brutal you're better off not
buying the salad skipping dinner
not buying that gift than paying five
dollars for a cup of coffee and then
paying 150 in late fees
similar to hard conversations at work
with your spouse with your girlfriend or
boyfriend have the conversation god help
us all
come on donna you have to rep parent pet
parents better than that have the
conversation we'll be right back on the
doctor
whatever on my show bye
[Music]
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john dolone show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos i've reached out
and there's a six month waiting list or
i can't afford it or they only take
insurance or i can't get off work and
time to go see somebody it's way across
town what do i do because i want help
with my anxiety my depression my
relationships are hanging on by a thread
i want to be a better mom i gotta
process this trauma that happened to me
when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor so i
partnered with betterhelp because
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapists if
you reach out to them you will be
talking to somebody within 48 hours dr
john daloni show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com
deloney
all right we are back with mean dean in
prescott arizona sydney prescott hello
sydney what's up dean
hey
john delany how you doing i'm remarkable
dean what's up
hey i had a question i was wondering how
do i better show my wife dignity and the
respect that she deserves
man
that feels like that feels like a loaded
question how are you not showing her
dignity and respect let's start there
well so
i grew up and my my parents got divorced
when i was about six and um
my dad isn't very respectful to
um just women in general whether it be
my stepmom my mom or my sisters how not
give me an example of how he's not
uh emotionally uh abusive
verbally and just um
yeah just manipulative and all the
narcissistic ways and things like that
so give me give me an example
um so i'm your mom and i was gonna i i
was leaving early in the morning
and i said um hey i'm your stepmom and
i'm gonna go hang out with some friends
today and then i'll have dinner ready at
5 30. and then all of a sudden hanging
out with my friends turns into a couple
of drinks we have a great day and then
two friends show up and we haven't seen
them in a while and i don't get home
till six
and your dad's at home at 5 30. what
does he say
that would have never happened because
of the fear of the
silent treatment and being
um
alienated uh so he was a a he used
silence as a weapon
yeah so like and like another thing
about him is that um he sent me an email
about two years ago telling me that he
didn't want to talk to me or my siblings
anymore and he was justifying that my
parent like him cheating on my mom
originally was because he did it for her
so she could have a way out of the
relationship oh what a sweet guy
what a yeah right
a hero
[Laughter]
so it sounds like your dad is trapped in
a nine-year-old brain and body
yeah i'd say so um and probably for a
thousand reasons i don't want to give
him a pass but he's a child
and
he
just took his ball and i'm going home
yeah and when somebody says when the
when the teacher says why did you kick
timmy and he said
cause timmy wanted to go home so i just
kicked him so he could go home i mean
just he's a he's an elementary school
kid
yeah and so
he weaponized relationships that's what
happens when you use silence as a weapon
so you can hit somebody you can swear at
somebody or you can
cut ties
and it's a
man i that has been my weapon of choice
and it's evil man it's it's the number
one thing i'm working on in my life
so
now you've got tell me about your kids
yeah so i have a two-year-old daughter
and a nine-month-old daughter
dude can we just stop for a second and
say high five to you brother what made
what made this come up
what a stud man that you looked at your
dad and said i'm not doing that
well it's been a long process and um
just being able to to see me and um
look at myself like third person and see
what i'm doing i could be doing better
to
uh change my family tree generationally
so i don't you know bro dude you're a
stud man that's incredible
is your uh did you marry will
yeah absolutely my wife is an absolute
angel and i definitely um i'm married up
for sure out kicked your coverage that's
awesome dude all right
so
is is there a behaviors in yourself
that you recognize
and your goal and your first thought is
whoa i don't like that
yeah so i think that um especially in
our first a little bit of marriage about
two years or so i would
i was you know dealing with a lot of my
own personal issues and so i would
um
i would also alienate myself because i
felt like i was hurting her or something
like that and so i would just kind of
leave
um like emotionally or physically just
for a little bit and it wasn't what she
needed and then also i think i just um
those manipulative tendencies tendencies
um i would use um but i try to be uh
acknowledge those things
and to not do it um once that when i can
can see that i am doing something
manipulative very cool so
on the other side so now i'm going to do
something that's going to be
uncomfortable for you and i'm going to
give your dad a quick moment of grace
on the other side of his immaturity
that feeling when you start feeling like
i can't do anything right
and if i say anything else it's gonna
hurt my wife
so what i'm gonna do is turn the game on
and i'm gonna unplug to protect her
from me
and there's a
true like a real true i can see the
narrative in your dad's head
which is the best thing for me is if
they are not around me how do i blow
this up because i don't have the courage
to say hey i wanna i wanna leave
um or i want my kids to not be around me
because i'm not good so i'm gonna write
them this immature letter and act like
does that make sense so your feelings
are
it's the story you were born into with
your old man right
oh man so here's man i got a little girl
so i'm just gonna rattle off a few
things that i've struggled with and that
i'm wrestling with
and
um you jump in if anything sounds right
or
you think ooh i like that okay
okay
the first one is
always leaning into
when i think the world would be better
when i think my daughter or my son or my
wife would be better with me gone
i have to lean in the other way like a
salmon i gotta swim upstream of that
feeling
and i gotta do it quietly
and so often i try to when i gear myself
to come back and swim upstream so my
body is saying dude just get out of here
then i want you around so i go to hug my
daughter and she's like no dad no
and my first thought is yeah cause you
suck at being a dad
that's incorrect i don't i'm gonna
challenge that thought with evidence and
i don't suck at being a dad but my
five-year-old doesn't want to me hugging
her or poking on her or making jokes at
five in the morning
so i'm gonna lean back into that
and i'm not gonna say anything i might
pat her on the head
or i might just touch her hand or i
might just sit down at the table and
drink my cup of coffee right across the
table from her so i'm gonna lean into
that when my every impulse i have is to
run
because my kid my daughter's going to
internalize me running as she did
something
and i don't want to give her that much
power
she doesn't have that much power over me
she's five
same with my wife
there are times when i just want to
disappear like man i'm just gonna fine
and i'm not doing that anymore i'm gonna
lean and say out loud
my impulse is to pull away here because
i feel like i am i'm not saying the
right things
um
can you help me where are we
would your wife talk to you if you ask
her a question like that
oh absolutely okay absolutely so instead
of giving advice ask questions
okay not weapon questions either like
why are you wearing that or what's wrong
with you that's our weapon questions
those are bull crap but
i feel like i'm missing the mark here
how can i best honor you right now
and let that's a risk because she may
say get the crap out of my get out of my
face and that could hurt
but it's a risk but we're gonna do that
the second one is to really be
intentional about respecting your
daughter's bodies and here's what i mean
by that
my tin is i may have talked about this
on the show um i've never talked about
it live
my
tendency
is i'll say hey josephine come give me a
hug
and she'll say no i don't want to
and my tendency is to use my dad powers
and to say i'm your dad i told you to do
a thing come do it now
and she will begrudgingly because i'm
dad i've got bigger muscles than her i
got power
but what i'm teaching her is at some
point some man will have autonomy over
your body
and they will get to tell you what to do
with your body and this turns into
that didn't hurt and she's saying yes it
did
and you're getting into her body and
telling her what her feelings are or you
shouldn't even be that sad i'm thinking
of her in middle school and the boy
breaks up with her and someone she has a
crush on just dumps her and she's
heartbroken and you say ah just shake it
off it's all good
that
teaches her body your feelings are not
to be trusted you need to find some man
that will
have your feelings for you
and so what i'm really combating in my
own self is when my daughter says that
hurt
i say i'm sorry that hurt now my first
thought is no it doesn't that didn't
hurt at all
or my first thought is when she says no
dad i say
thank you for using kind of words and
then i move on about my day because that
hug was for me not for her
and so respecting their body
um and that goes into respecting their
thoughts and
man and then the last one here is
show up
just keep showing up and keep showing up
and keep showing up and if you can show
up with your little ones at eye level
get down on the floor and look them in
the eye
that gives them a sense of connection
that kind of equalizes that power
dynamic and it's really magical
especially with a young young young one
it's incredible oh i got one more
are you ready for this one
i think so
take care of yourself
exercise
have guy friends
um take go out once a week with your
buddies
and keep connected to them
have a life have a
spiritual life of some sort um
get counseling if you need it you get a
lot of trauma growing up with an
immature dad and a divorce and all that
stuff deal with that stuff
and come home whole
so your kids can have something to
anchor into
how's that okay that sounds perfect
sounds like a lot and love their mom
like crazy like crazy hug her a lot if
she's
cool with that kiss a lot be
affectionate show her what love looks
like
okay because you are going to be the
picture in your daughter's mind of oh
this is what a man does this is what
love looks like this is what
a romantic relationship looks like
and um even if the person they're going
to marry is nothing like you
you're giving the picture of what that
looks like um but i think overall man
the fact that you're asking this
question for a two-year-old and a seven
month old dude
you're so far ahead high five to you
anybody out there listening who had
parents who sucked or parents who were
going through their own stuff and didn't
show up or parents who wrote you a
letter and said i'm not being your
friend anymore whatever
man have the courage to turn and face
that storm because whatever you pass on
to your kids gets passed on to their
kids and so on and so forth you have the
strength to turn and stop and say this
ends with me good for you good for you
dean from arizona my brother all right
we'll be right back on the dr john de
luna show
the world has become more and more
chaotic and uncertain and loud and it
seems that everyone has anxiety i've
been there and so have you it's why i
wrote this small direct and personal
book called redefining anxiety in this
book i discuss what anxiety is what it's
not and how you can get back on the road
of being whole and well listen
you are not broken and i'm living proof
that you can get your life back i wrote
this book so everyone could read it not
just science nerds like me and my
friends and i priced it at 10 bucks so
that everyone can afford it this little
book landed on the best seller list and
is now being purchased by the case and
given away in counseling offices
universities churches and homes across
the country i don't care if you're a
teenager or an executive or a 75 year
old grandmother this book is for
everyone so go to johndeloney.com and
get your copy of redefining anxiety
today
all right let's take unimas let's go to
tomi in bentonville arkansas bentonville
home of walmart is that right tommy
it's the home of walmart and crystal
bridges
i don't know crystal bridges do they
sell drugs there what is crystal bridge
you know what it sounds like they do
don't they it's a fun place to go visit
lots of lights outdoor trails
there's no drugs at crystal crystal
village
it does kind of sound like a mystical
place where it does doesn't it yeah but
yes walmart's here there are no drugs at
walmart none
never so what's up t-money how can i
help it
well dr john my parents are my in-laws
they actually just got a job where they
have the summers off
and they
wanna i i'm laughing at you not with you
on this one
i know because i i'm not i'm not
laughing i was
until it became real
oh man okay so i i'm just guessing where
this is headed but go ahead
they would love to spend a month with
each kid
and their kids and their spouses
yes and
um and so they did tell us originally
they said we could stay in an extended
stay
but then they haven't brought that up
again but i do know a month with them
here means they're every day
with
um
my wife and me and it just it doesn't it
sounds so exciting
yes dude i'm so happy for you you know
what you're gonna have someone to
critique how you mow the lawn how you
make breakfast how you what you watch at
night when you go to bed you're closed
it'll be so good now not all in-laws are
like that if my in-laws wanted to move
in for a month i would love that it'd be
incredible oh great it doesn't sound
like that is your situation tell me
about it
so my in-laws they they truly are great
people
they would be your conservative
religious
uh
type of person i guess if i put a
stereotype um they might i'll put it
this way my wife just let her mom know
this year that we drink alcohol
and uh we're in our 30s
yes
i was going to make a joke but that i'm
not even going to go there
how did that conversation go was it hard
uh it was hard for my wife
but because you know she's never really
separated herself
uh in a conversation like that with her
parents and it was really healthy her
mom responded well her dad is the one
that i think
you know he's pretty legalistic because
he's aware of the highway it's his
interpretation of the bible or no way um
and he just
you know he's not talkative he's not
conversationalist
just hard to be around for an extended
period of time okay
so i i think that my concern dr john is
i think it's great that we differentiate
from her parents but i you know i'm like
more than three nights a week for a
month sounds like a whole lot and and i
want to live my life in the month of
june
yes so two two questions what is number
one what does your wife think of this
uh i have more anxiety than she does so
she she has asked me before
you know why why does that make you
anxious and do you tell the truth
i do yeah i do tell her the truth yeah
even when you say do you say things like
i don't like you when you're around them
because you regress 20 years and you
become a 10 year old and it becomes
awkward for us are you that i haven't
said that no i haven't said that is it
truthful
um i don't think she regresses 20 years
i do think that she
uh doesn't want you know she doesn't
want to offend her parents okay so i
think that i think i need to have that
conversation with her i don't want to
offend my parents but i also don't
consider my life an offense
do you see the difference there
yeah like yeah i see what you're saying
i will not bring whiskey like in your
situation i wouldn't bring
even fancy bourbon i wouldn't bring it
into my parents house
yes but i'm not going to
deceive them and go through a big hiding
ritual every time they're coming over
when i'm in my 30s i'm not gonna do that
and you know what what's funny is i do
collect fancy whiskey and we used to
hide it and then it was like we're not
doing this anymore and so you can see
we're just at the beginning stages there
you go okay trying to be healthy with my
in-laws yeah okay cool
so that's why i have anxiety around this
yeah so do and the second question is do
you have little kids
i do we have a nine-year-old they're
both girls nine-year-old and
six-year-old okay all right
man
so
i can speak from like if my in-laws want
to come i'd love that i think it'd be
fun but here's the differentiation
i live my life
and my wife and i are
completely differentiated from our
parents
meaning we do what we do
and if there's a sunday that we don't
want to go to church but we want to
spend it as a family and we're going to
go hiking and do our thing and that's
what we do
i don't feel like i gotta hide from
people
if i have my dad and i have radically
different political views my mom and i
have we are in sync on some things
super nonsync and other things some
things my dad and i
i just i don't care
you know what i mean like i'm interested
in the intellectual sparring
but i'm not going to fight anybody
especially not my parents or my in-laws
you know what i mean and so i
i'm there
what i
would caution you on is
you're just in a hard place brother
because your your in-laws
did a couple of things number one they
gave you the old well we could just stay
in an extended stay motel
all right
great cool y'all go ahead and do that
you can do that
and
um if i don't know how that would fly i
know how to fly my house
um
so the second thing is now i mean the
kind of introduce themselves into your
home second thing is it sounds like
there's some marital tension here
and you've got to be very careful about
talking bad about your wife's parents
is she sensitive about that
no she's been really gracious and she
sees it uh she sees that hey we have
totally different lives than her parents
and we've we've even talked about so she
has done really well and i do feel like
i'd be honest with her um and i've told
her it it is hard for me to be around
your dad for an extended period of time
okay tell me why why is it hard
yeah i've been
uh like why do you care and i'm just
gonna sound i'm being provocative on
purpose why do you care if he just wants
to sit over there
and watch fox news and be angry let him
like why why does that bother you
well that that is a fault for of mine
for sure because i think i'm like let's
do something and let's engage in
conversation or let's
have fun together i i i think for me
that's what i would like to do
and it i don't i don't know why it
bothers me so much
i wish i hadn't
do you wish this is going to be a hard
do you wish he liked you
or is there a sense that your
father-in-law just doesn't like you that
much or would like you more if you had
different life views or different
lifestyles
yeah i think i think i feel like i'm
being judged by him
when we're not engaging in a
relationship there you go
and you feel like he's not in a
relationship with you because of some
judgment he's placed on you
possibly yes yes
okay now i feel like we're getting at
the core issue here
you my friend
need to be confident tommy
okay and you need to be confident as
a husband of a great wife
as of the dad of two great daughters
yeah and more importantly you need to be
confident in these are my life choices
these are my life philosophies these are
my life
decisions and it's mine
and if somebody wants to be a guest in
my house that's fantastic i would be
hospitable and kind and if they don't
want to talk to me
that is their loss
because i'm pretty awesome
and i'm going to go talk to other people
or i'm going to take my kids and we're
all going to go fishing and if my
father-in-law wants to sit down and
stare at his phone that's a choice he's
gonna make but i'm not gonna own his
choice
and what i would tell you is you're
chasing a fantasy and i'm not saying
it's an ugly you're chasing a fantasy
that there is going to be a thing one
day y'all are going to align
and i want to tell you you are not
there won't be an alignment
there may be a arms like a ceasefire
like in my in my house we made some
rules no politics no covet like we can't
talk about it
so i made those conversation cards like
where i refuse to have these
conversations just because it doesn't
doesn't get anywhere
um and so we are done with this
um in fact yeah i'm gonna do this i'm
gonna give you i'm gonna send you three
decks of cards i'm gonna send them to
you okay
uh and whenever this inevitably happens
which is going to you can practice over
the holidays and then when they move in
with you
and gee it's so great
uh you can have them but they're just
cards like hey here's some other things
to talk about
and
if he chooses not to engage what i want
you to begin practicing is
it's not your responsibility to chase
down a relationship with him it's your
responsibility to be respectful and
those are two different things
this is so helpful does that make sense
yeah do i do you think i need to sit
down with or call him and just say
hey
this is kind of who i am you know
this is do i need to have that
conversation with them about when you're
in our house all the things that you
said about
you know our house is if we have a glass
of wine together fine if we want to go
out together with the kids
so is that a healthy conversation to
have i
i
one of my life rules is to speak to be
heard not to have having said had said
something
and i said that kind of bonkers
there are some people that when when an
action happens like an injustice happens
or somebody gets offended or whatever
they make sure that they spoke on that
issue
i want on the record that i said
something about that it's like living
your life like a politician
i choose to only speak when i can be
heard
what that often means is i'm not posting
stuff the day after something happened
because everybody's fired up nobody's
listening
or my father-in-law has the way he lives
it's the way he lives
and so if i call him what he will hear
in about eight seconds
is i don't like the way you live and if
you're coming into my house you're going
to live like this
and then he's going to turn into an old
labrador and see who can pee up the tree
the highest
and again i'm speaking into your
father-in-law i don't know that guy from
the man on the moon
i'm telling you i would more like to
take all of the air and drama out i
don't know that it's worthy of a
conversation you have a glass of wine at
dinner
great
when he's there and y'all are having
dinner
then you say hey you guys want a glass
of wine
and you just like as though it is hey
will you pass the fork
because right now it's y'all's heart
rate that's getting up not theirs
and then if they come to your house and
you all respectfully offer them a glass
of your nicest wine
and they decline and then they want to
throw grown-up temper tantrums about
that that's their challenge not yours
okay
and so i'm more interested in
yeah if there's one or two things that
you think would be fun if he likes to go
ride go-karts or go fishing or go
hunting whatever it is if you think
there's things there that would be great
yeah set him up see if he wants to go he
might just say no i don't want to go
and then you got to swallow it and go
that's his issue not mine
and by the way i'm
dating his daughter so i win uh you know
what i mean
um and he may just
he you may be thinking about y'all's
relationship way more than he is
yeah well i would like
i mean my there's things i want with my
own dad that i don't have yeah and i
know
see now we're getting out the issue i
know we are and i know that i'm like oh
i don't want to be and you're trying to
transfer your dad's you and your dad's
relationship issues and try to recreate
something with your father-in-law yeah i
think so and what i want you to do is
let that fantasy go
okay shake the man's hand when he comes
over here's the thing he's probably
coming over for a month i wish he could
be like no we're going to say no he's
probably coming
and so
sit down and make peace with like your
life decisions and decide to not hide
what i will tell you is secrets or
poison
and secrets will destroy your marriage
secrets will destroy relationship with
your in-laws
don't keep secrets this is who we are
this is how we live now that doesn't
mean we're gonna like
have a discussion on who should be
president that's not gonna be helpful no
um but my guess is that's not your style
anyway
no i don't i don't care to have those
talks
and if y'all you know if he grew up
baptist and a strong baptist family and
now y'all go to a different church
that's just where you go don't hide
don't lie don't hide it be proud of who
you are and what decisions you're making
and if you all want to make different
decisions make different decisions but
all of this yeah man we got to it took a
few minutes but
you got some challenges between you and
your dad
and you want to make sure that's not
replicated and you see your
father-in-law's a chance to fix that and
it's not
the way you fix that is in your
relationship with your kids
and the way you can fix that is being
open and loving your nine-year-olds and
being connected to them and letting them
see you have friends and let them see
you not be tense with your life choices
own them own them
own them and be respectful super
respectful
super respectful of your in-laws it's
their choices
um and it may be that hey we're gonna
take the tv out of from downstairs
because i don't want this news blaring
24 7 when they're here they can go
upstairs and listen to it or they can go
in the back room and listen to it we'll
put a tv in your room y'all can just sit
back there and watch tv all you want but
out here we don't watch tv we got
puzzles out we got games out we got
whatever we got the
questions for humans cards that i'm
going to send you so hang on the line
tommy and um kelly will get your
information she'll mail them out to you
and that's just my gift to you to save
your family that's all that's all they
do they just save your family i probably
overstated that a little bit but
tommy you'd be proud of tommy man
love tommy tommy's a good guy he's a
good dad he's a good husband
he's a good guy and if your old man
comes around that's even better
but own tommy let's move on from there
all right man um let's see let's wrap it
up
with uh man i think i've talked about
them
i saw this band open up for indigo girls
man at the ryman
i was with some friends we went to
indigo girl shows like high school all
over again it's incredible
and war on treaty opened up and holy
smokes are incredible
they are incredible
this record man
get on spotify today or get on the
internets and buy every warrant and
treaty record you can they're so good
and if you want to watch them live man
they
cali find where they're playing
this is off the 2018 healing tide album
the song is called hearts and it goes
like this
on this road i've learned it doesn't
make sense without you without you and
i'd rather be a passenger on a moving
train if it meant i'd be next to you
by the skin of my teeth and the hairs on
my head i'd be lost if i didn't have you
just a ball of confusion a life left in
void that's what i'd be without you
this is a love song right here cause
right would be wrong if we spent time
alone separate in the dark with the
light still left on oh my gosh
it wouldn't be much to try to keep our
love apart because we'd find each
other's hearts we'd find each other's
hearts in this life i've learned it
don't mean a thing without you without
you and i'd rather be
a [ __ ] using you as my cane if it
meant i could lean
on
you war on treaty
bringing it from the soul
god i love those guys it's so good
husband and wife team go check them out
it's been awesome see you soon on the dr
john delaney show